while an island off the coast of
Scotland something was summoned from the
depths of hell
something that would end mankind usurp
things he worried about today show up
oh yes
you sir yes or a part of one of the
craziest kisses I've ever seen oh yeah
yeah what can you tell me about shooting
that scene oh man that was not a fun
dive that was not a fun time
the lovely individual who plays that
particular which in the movie is this
terrific guy Troy who is a contortionist
who's incredible his movement was
incredible as this character the makeup
was disgusting and scary and there was
this moment when you know and Troy was
very lovely hadn't done that many films
and so he was very respectful as we
began this process of the kiss moment
and then the director and I both
encouraged him I was like Troy we really
want to sell this so let's go for it you
know what I mean and Troy really decided
to use his tongue in all sorts of ways
luckily I had an entire latex mask in
front but even then it was uncomfortable
for both of us we really went through
and experienced that day that was quite
a yeah the tongue just like you're like
guys like yeah I now I know now I know I
feel so I will be trust me
yeah what's something that you've never
done that you would love to do just for
the hell of it love to do for the hell
of it I mean the first thing that jumps
to mind because I'm not really like like
I hate the ocean I'm terrified of like
the ocean like even nature with like
super ticks and spiders like I'm not so
but the one thing I kind of am into
which I've never done is jump out of an
airplane and like parachute or whatever
I guess they call it skydiving my brain
could work jump out of an airplane
something I'd like to do forth a little
bit as long as you're not falling in the
ocean yeah yeah I'd want to hit land I
definitely want to hit laughs that would
suck could you imagine pie repairs you
to get into the ocean
what if Hellboy had to do stuff in the
ocean is that I can now go for yeah that
would be like about if you went to hell
and came back who would you haunt and
why would I
yeah wow so many people
I mean I'm mad at so many people he's
like I guess I would haunt like concepts
like I would haunt like big old
institutions that I have problems with
in like the world you know things that
have made me feel mmm
made me feel sort of less than and
outcast for a lot of my life and not
included and so I'd haunt those those
things that's a very obscure answer I
wish I could be more specific but I'd
probably get sued in some way what is
something that you've never done that
you would like to do just for the hell
of it I make a billion dollars you have
made a billion dollars I haven't made a
billion dollars yet I feel left out of
the club contrary to popular no I don't
know I mean um you know what I've never
done hand gliding and that's something
that is always sort of like attracted me
but now that I have kids I'm like I
would never but I'm kind of sad that I
never did that before I had kids so
you'll never do it no okay I could see
you rocking that I mean I dunno - well
maybe if it was for a movie or something
that would be great because then it
would be like safer right but if you
went to hell and came back who would you
haunt and why funny questions there's
probably a few people that pop to mind
but I don't want to get political is
there anyone non-political that you
would haunt I don't know I probably just
like haunt all my friends just to be
annoying what do you hope people take
away from this movie um you know I think
this movie is so much about people who
are marginalized people who are
ostracized the hero you know my
character the people that I lead my
people the monsters
you know it's so much about finding
acceptance and I think it's it's very
relatable in today's society you know we
see such powerful women in office today
that are constantly just trying to be
taken down like people men in this world
are just trying to take them down all
the time and I found that so amazing
because I felt I related to that aspect
about my characters she's a powerful
woman with big ideas and boom
immediately she gets buried alive and
you know I feel like this movie is very
apropos it's very relevant to what we're
experiencing today on an everyday basis
made me a damn weapon I just wanted to
help you become the best
you
[Applause]
some dads get their kids Legos what are
some of the things that Hellboy this new
Hellboy can and can't do I read
somewhere that this Hellboy can't have
sex are there other things that oh no
the Hellboy can't do this but well you
know this is a complete new Hellboy joke
to everything because it's a reboot
there's nothing to do with the first one
no I don't think I think the very look
of the character unless David brings
such you manage to do it they may have
sex in the next one you never know you
know with whatever they do whoever they
decide to bring into it no I think
that's that there's rules of the game
whenever a show or like Harry Potter's a
magic show right they can do magic they
can open new magic so that's a given
within the Bible of that show Sioux
Avenger shows they all have special
skills they can all do something is that
there's a show that I do on American
Gods which is they're all old gods but
they can't do Harry Potter things and
they can't do Avengers things because
that's too easy if you make your
characters yeah they got to learn things
even in those Avengers movies they've
got to earn them a challenge it's just
too easy to do something Hellboy no I
mean he can he can do things but his
power must be earned by you know the
talk about what am i I'm a creature from
Hell which is born with these weird
things he can do he can't be destroyed
in a certain sense he can but he's the
spawn of the devil but he was found by
this supposedly good guy which is me the
the fart Trevor brought in home who's
become a sort of life coach if you like
but only on one side the fact is there
are monsters out there son and they'll
get you before you get them so he's made
you son into a killing machine and
because he's one of them and the kids
now asking questions around I don't I
like these people I kill I'm a half a
month I mean maybe they might maybe
you're not right all the time so that's
the kind of a nice moral dilemma for the
film to go through while it Lots off a
thousand heads and blood gets in your
face of people scream and scare each
other to death because that's what they
want to do in the shapes on - they don't
want to be they don't want morals trust
in that face all the time but they do
like a little of the chat if it's right
and it's also funny and its own sort of
deadpan where time doesn't try too hard
to be funny it looks fabulous and yeah I
think it ends it stripes as a reboot in
every conceivable way
that's I love it thank you for that's
great what is something you've never
done that you would love to do just for
the hell of it I skate you've never been
ice skating
I would love to ice skate I still live
in the beach in Venice and I see people
skateboarding I think you know I don't
think I'm gonna try it much as I love it
but I escape maybe I'll get something
you can just pull me around the ring
like that when I'm in New York in about
6 months time no it's one of those funny
things you didn't I will never ask you
about this kid people say you know did
you did you have a ski I said no didn't
when I was a kid no it couldn't afford
that skin that came later on you know
when they will the cheap one days to
perish but yes anything to do with snow
love it but you know it's problem
throwing a snowball the rest is a
mystery if you went to hell and cowboy
the snowball a snowball's chance in hell
dealt with I was what going carry on the
second movie if you went to hell and
came back who would you haunt and why oh
if I was a Helen to come back I don't
know I wouldn't you know no I wouldn't
do it to anybody I probably come no if I
know I just I sent some clowns and knock
on somebody's door 3:00 in the morning
see how they reacted in the outfit you
know me thank you know exactly smiley
wimple oh my god smiling wimple it's
2:00 in the morning no I said scarier in
the clown yeah hello face on
yeah koalas dude
what is something that you've never done
that you would like to do just for the
hell of it this is a family channel yeah
no really I can't
but what would I what would I do that
I've never done before
I'm so intrigued now I'll give you an
actor II answer I'd like to go back and
do some more Shakespeare how's that okay
I've done Shakespeare that but not not
all the roles that I would like to
that's so pretentious you'll cut this
like what Shakespeare play I don't know
what is Shakespeare no I like what no I
like Henry the fifths a lot I I think
given our political climate we could use
someone to inspire us as a leader and
that's a pretty great story if you went
to hell and came back and had to haunt
someone who would you haunt oh my gosh
it's one of these interviews okay if I
went to hell and came back and I had to
haunt someone and it can't be
Shakespeare
would it be someone like his haunting
can be a good thing or a bad thing I
guess just follow someone I you know I
just I'd want to just check in on all my
friends and family make sure they're
okay what do you want people to take
away from this movie you know I just the
feeling that it's uh it's a bit of a
roller coaster ride like you know that
feeling that after you get off an
amusement park ride that you take a deep
breath and you go wow that was something
if they could come up with walk away
with that feeling from this movie that'd
be great
you